for more than 250 years it's been a key
ingredient of French cuisine we're going
to make a typical French mousse au
chocolat using my mother's recipe as a
patissier Cyril jaha knows his way
around French desserts for the past two
and a half years he's been working at
the luxury hotel and restaurant or
beverage Dubois in the French ski resort
of Sharm Oni that's right across from
Mont Blanc the tallest mountain in
Europe stealing Jetta takes care of the
sweet stuff while the lunch is being
prepared he only needs four ingredients
sugar butter chocolate and eggs
first he melts the butter and chocolate
in a pan it's really important that the
chocolate isn't too cold otherwise it
will harden again when you mix it with
the egg yolk he recommends using
chocolate with a high percentage of
cocoa you can buy the chocolate for the
mousse in any supermarket but it should
be at least 50% cocoa the lower the
percentage the more chocolate you'll
need to use the jedis using chocolate
with 66% cocoa the danique Xavier owns
the restaurant he usually orders in bulk
but today he's shopping in a local
chocolate shop
the shaka latinos what makes a good
moose you can use all types of chocolate
it's all about the balance if you use a
very strong chocolate then you need a
lot of sugar to counter the bitterness
but you can make a mousse out of any
kind of chocolate when the dark of white
or milk chocolate meanwhile syria has
melted the chocolate and he is now
separating the eggs he mixes the yolks
with sugar it's important to stir for a
long time so the sugar binds with the
yolk the yolks would be a little foamy
then he beats the egg whites and mixes
the melted chocolate with the egg yolk
the egg whites shouldn't be beaten too
long if the egg white is too stiff then
it will flake later he gently folds a
bit of egg white into the chocolate mix
to lighten it then he slowly adds the
rest
fold it carefully so that the egg white
doesn't fall in on itself the mousse has
to stay really light the dessert is
almost ready
it just has to cool in the fridge for
three hours to firm it up a little in
the end the mousse should be Aryan not
too heavy otherwise it will just get
slushy mousse au chocolat is always the
right choice every day all year round
it's a gourmets dessert for Igor mousse
au chocolat every day now there's a
sweet temptation